ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้
นักเรียนเย้
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนผมมากโอเควันนี้กลับมา
เจอกับเทียบตี้แล้วกลับมาเจอกับน้องเรียม
ในช่องของซีเอ็นซีเบิ้ลไทยนะครับอยู่ด้าน
ไหนด้านนี้อ่ะโอเค
ครับผมอ้าวันนี้เรามาเจอกันวันนี้
วันนี้วัน
อะไรนะวันนี้วันอะไรครับวันนี้วันอะไรวัน
นี้วันอะไรวันพุธ
วันนี้วันพุธใช่ครับวันพุธวันพุธ
วันพุธหน้านี้ครับ
วันพุธหาสถานที่ที่วันที่ 4 ครับหน้าวัน
นี้วันที่ 4 วันพุธที่ 4 วาล์ว
เดือนอะไรคะอ่าอันนี้อ่าเดือนนี้เดือน
พฤษภาคมครับ
หน้าปีพตอะไรคะตีพ.ต.พต
2565 ขับ
แล้วปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2000  22 ครับปีนี้
โอเคตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้ว
อ่ะตอนนี้เวลา
10:00 น
10:00  10 นน่ะเป็นตอนเช้า
ทานหนาวแค่เดี๋ยววันนี้วันนี้อ่าเรามาเรา
หนังกันเหมือนเดิมใช่ไหมครับตอนนี้เดี๋ยว
เฮียตี๋จะเป็นคนเล่าให้น้องเดียวฟังนะ
ครับน้าๆ
วันนี้เพียบที่ฉันเล่าหนังเรื่องอะไรคะ
เป็นหนังแท้ที่เกี่ยวกับเกมเกมอะน้อง
เลี้ยงเล่นเกมไหมครับเล่นเกมไหมเตรียม
เล่นเกมหน่อยขอเล่นเกมนิดหน่อยใช่ไหมครับ
อ่าพี่ก็เล่นนิดหน่อยเหมือนกันอ่ะไม่ได้
เล่นเยอะๆบางคนเล่นเกมเยอะๆเฮียตีคิดว่า
นักเรียนนักเรียนก็น่าจะเล่นเกมด้วย
เหมือนกันนะโอเค
หนังมหา G เพียงดีจากเล่านี้เกี่ยวกับ
เกี่ยวกับเกมส์
น้าเกี่ยวกับเกมใส่เข้าเกม
เกมแบบไหนคะพี่อาร์ตี้เล่นเกมส์ต่อสู้
แล้วก็ยิงกันน้าเก็บคะแนนยิ่งยิ่งอายอิ้ง
คนร้ายอย่ายิงคนร้ายได้มากยิ่งได้หลายๆคน
ก็ได้คะแนนเยอะน่าได้ครับอ๋อ
แล้วมันเป็นเกมต่อไปใช่ไหมคะพี่อาหารใช่
ครับเป็นเกมออนไลน์เล่นได้หลายๆคนเกม
ออนไลน์เล่นจากที่ไหนก็ได้อ่าสายครับ
อยากดูแล้วค่ะวันนี้อยากรู้แล้วใช่ไหมว่า
เรื่องอะไรนี่ครับเรื่องนี้อ้าเคยดูไหม
เรื่องนี้ครับอ่ะฟรีกาย
เรียวไม่เคยดู
ครับในเกมเนี่ยอ้าเวลาที่เราเข้าไปเล่น
เกมในเกมก็จะมี
ผู้เล่นเป็นคนเล่นสมุน jt น้องอินเข้าไป
เข้าไปในเกมก็เป็นคนไปใกล้เพื่อนเก็บ
คะแนนได้คะแนนเยอะๆนะครับอ่ะแล้วก็จะมีคน
ที่เป็นตัวประกอบตัวประกอบที่อยู่ในเกม
ตัวประกอบก็ไม่ได้เป็นคนเล่นไม่ได้เป็นมา
เล่นเป็นตัวประกอบนะครับอ่ะในหนังเรื่อง
นี้นางเรื่องนี้พลีกายฟรีกายก็คือผู้ชาย
คนนี้
ผู้ชายชื่อฟรีกายคนนี้เนี่ยเป็นตัวประกอบ
ไม่ได้เป็นคนเล่นเกม
น้าสีกลายเป็นตัวประกอบแล้วคนนี้เป็น
เพื่อนของฟรีกายนะคนนี้ก็เป็นตัวประกอบ
เหมือนกันไม่ได้เป็นคนจริงๆ
นะเป็นตัวประกอบอยู่ในเค้กอ๊อฟมีเกมๆไม่
ได้เป็นคนจริงๆนะครับแล้วก็มีอันนี้เป็น
ผู้หญิงคนนี้ผู้หญิงหรือชื่อบิลลี่บิลลี่
เป็นคนจริงๆที่เข้าไปเล่นในเกม
อ้ามิลลี่แล้วก็มีเพื่อนของมิลลี่เพื่อน
ของมิลลี่ r0 คนนี้เป็นคนที่สร้างเกม
อ้าโอเคตอนนี้รู้จักทุกคนแล้วใช่ไหมครับ
อ่ะ We  Are  5 อย่าใช่ในเกมในเกมก็จะมี
ตัวประกอบ
ตัวประกอบที่อยู่ในเกมตัวประกอบนี้ไม่ใช่
คนจริงๆไม่มีจริงๆเป็นเอ่อเกมอยู่ในเกม
มีอยู่แล้วในเกมใช่ไหมที่เรียงเวลาเล่ม
เข้าไปเล่นเกมมันก็จะมีแบบตำรวจตำรวจที่
อยู่ในเกมใช่ชายเขาก็มีอะไรนะ
มีแบบคนที่ทำงาน
ออฟฟิศจิ๋วในกล้าทรายครับอันนั้นคือว่า
ตัวประกอบชายใช่ๆฟรีกายก็เป็นตัวประกอบ
อยู่ในเกมอ่ะเพื่อนของปีกลายก็เป็นตัว
ประกอบอยู่ในเกมในครับส่วนมิลี่วิลลี่
เป็นผู้หญิงที่อยู่ข้างนอกเป็นคนจริงๆ
เป็นคนจริงๆแล้วเข้าไปเข้าไปเล่นเกมเพิ่ง
เก็บจะเก็บคะแนนหน้านะครับโอเคอะนี่ก็คือ
เรื่องของฟรีกายนะครับ
โอเคมันจะเกิดอะไรขึ้นค่ะพี่
ครับอยากรู้ว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นแล้วใช่ไหมอ่ะ
ในเกมนี้เนี่ยในเกมนี้อ่าก็จะมีคนที่
login เข้าไปในเกมเวลาที่เข้าไปในเกมนะ
ครับเขาก็จะเข้าไปที่ตัวตัวของฟรีกาย
เนี่ยคือกลายเป็นพนักงานธนาคาร
หาพี่ชายเป็นพนักงานธนาคารนะครับในเกม
แล้วเวลามีคนเข้าไปในเกมก็เข้าไปต้น
ธนาคาร
เพื่อจะเอาเงินเอาเงินจากธนาคารนะครับ
ทุกวันเวลามีคนล็อกอินเข้าไป C กายก็อยู่
ที่ชั้นอาการก็มีคนการพ่นธนาคารบ่อยๆที่
กายก็คิดว่าเอ๊ะทำไมธนาคารนี้มีคนมาปล้น
บ่อยน๊านะครับ
แล้วคนที่จะได้จ่ายต้องคิดด้วยหรอคะพี่
อาร์ตี้อ้าฟรีกายที่ข้อดีด้วยหรออ่ะปกติ
คนที่อยู่ในเกมตัวประกอบในเกมก็จะไม่คิด
ไม่คิดฟรีกายเนี่ยเขาคิดเขาเริ่มคิดได้
ให้ครับ R เพราะว่าเพราะว่าอะไรรู้ไหม
ครับเพราะว่าฟรีกายเนี่ยไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ตัว
ประกอบปกติอ้าฟรีกลายเป็นตัวประกอบพิเศษ
ที่อยู่ในเกมอ่ะแตกต่างจากตัวประกอบคน
อื่นๆ
ไงครับพี่กายก็เลยสังเกตไม่เหมือน
ทำอ่ะก็ไม่เหมือนเพราะว่าซีไกลก็เห็น
เหมือนเองได้คนอื่นๆใช่ไม่เหมือนกันไม่ลด
ทำไมพี่กายคิดคิดได้ค่ะอ๋อคนอื่นคิดไม่
ได้ฮ่าๆๆครับโอเคที่ฟรีกายคลิปเองได้
เพราะว่าเพราะว่าอะไรเพราะว่าสองคนนี้
ครับสองคนนี้สองคนนี้เขาเป็นเพื่อนกัน 2
คนดีเขาเป็นคนเขียนโปรแกรมของเกมนี้
อาเขาเป็นคนเขียนโปรแกรมของเกมนี้ใช่ครับ
แล้ว 5 แล้วเกมนี้ตอนที่ตอนที่เกมนี้ถูก
เข้าไปใช้ r ของตัวนะครับขอตัวนคนนี้เป็น
คนสร้างเกม
ใช้อ่า
ใช้โค้ดเกมของสองคนนี้เอาไปใช้นะครับน้า
แอบเอาไปใช้เขาโบย Coach จะเอาไปใช้
เอาไปใส่ไว้ในเกมเกมนี้ๆ
สองคนนี้วิลลี่วิลลี่ก็เลยต้องไปตามหาไป
ตามหาโค้ดเกมของเขาที่อยู่ในเกมว่าอยู่
ที่ไหน
5 มิลลิก็เลยต้องเข้าไปในเกม
เข้าเป็นเกมแล้วไปหาไปหาว่าโค้ดเกมอยู่
ที่ไหน
เสร็จแล้วโค้ดเกมขอเกมของมิลลี่ที่เอาไป
ใช้ก็คือฟรีกายอ่ะ
ส่วนหนึ่งของโค้ชเกมอยู่ในสีจ่ายเป็นฟรี
จ่ายฟรีกายก็เลยคิดคิดเองได้ไม่เหมือนคน
อื่น
หาอยู่ครับคล้ายๆคล้ายๆกับ AI เลยนะคะๆ
ใช่ครับ We  Are ในโค้ดเกมมี AI อยู่นะ
ครับทำให้เขาคิดเองได้
ห่าแล้วตอนที่ซีกายเริ่มสงสัยเริ่มคิดว่า
เอ๊ะทำไมถึงมีคนที่เข้ามาในเกมเนี่ยทุกคน
เวลาเข้ามาเล่นเกมเขาใส่แว่นตา
ทุกคนใส่แว่นตานี่ครับเวลามิลลี่เข้าไปใน
เกมนี้นี่ก็ใส่แว่นตาไปรับเพื่อนของ
มิลลี่เข้าไปก็ใส่แว่นตาเหมือนกันฟรีกาย
ก็สงสัยทำไมใส่แว่นตา
หน้าครับแล้ววันนี้ใจทำยังไงคะพี่อ้ะสี
ขายก็เลยคิดว่าคิดว่าในแว่นตาต้องมีอะไร
แน่ๆวันหนึ่งเขาก็เลยเวลามีคนเข้ามาเล่น
เกมเขาก็เลยเข้าไปต่อสู้กับคนที่เข้ามา
เล่นเกมแล้วก็แย่งเอาแว่นตามาเอาแว่นตามา
ใส่
น้ำตาเอาหน่าไส้ทำหนี้
อ้าไป
แย่งเอาแว่นตาจากคนที่เข้ามาเล่นเกมเอามา
ใส่หน้า
แล้วเวลาที่เขาใส่แว่นตาเราเขาขับมองเห็น
อะไรคะอ้าเวลาที่เค้าใส่แว่นตาแล้วเขาก็
จะมองเห็นมองเห็นพันลัง
พลังของของคนของคนที่เข้ามาเล่นเกมนั้น 5
แล้วเวลาเขาใส่แว่นตาเขาก็เห็นพลังของตัว
เองนะครับเวลาเล่นเกมเราจะมีพลังใช่ไหม
ครับมีพลังอยู่มากแค่ไหนพอเล่นไปเรื่อยๆ
พลังก็จะลดลงลดลงแล้วเราก็ต้องไปเก็บไป
เก็บ Item อ่ะไปเก็บพลังไปเก็บคะแนนต่างๆ
ไปทำภารกิจ
เวลาเล่นเกมเราต้องทำภารกิจใช่มั้ยครับ
ให้
ดีแล้วค่ะหน้านี้ครับฝีทอที่เรียมเข้าไป
เข้าไปเล่นเกมเวลาที่เราพลังพลังน้อยๆ
ครับเดือนจะเห็นแบบเป็นสีแดงอ่าใช่ครับ
เป็นสีแดงน้อง
หาถ้าเกิดพลังมากขึ้นนิดนึง
ก็จะเห็นเป็นสีเหลือง
5 ใช่ครับก็จะยาวขึ้นแบบนี้อ่านี่ครับ
เป็นตารางหาหรือว่าพลังมากๆก็จะเป็นสี
เขียว
ครับพลังมากๆ
อาเสร็จแล้วจะเห็นอะไรไหมคะอ้าเพราะพี่
กายเห็นพลังมีกายก็เริ่มเริ่มรู้และว่า
อ้าวนี่อาเขาเขาไม่ได้เป็นคนจริงๆเขาเป็น
คนที่อยู่ในเกม
ro2 เขารู้เขาคิดว่าเขาเป็นคนที่อยู่ใน
เกมนี้นะครับตอนนั้นก็เขาก็ไปเจอกับ
มิลลี่พอดีมิลี่ที่เข้ามาเพื่อค้นหาโค้ด
เกมของเขาอ่ะเขาก็ไปเจอกับบิลลี่นี้ครับ
มิลลี่เข้ามานะครับเขาก็เกิดความรักกับ
มิลลี่เขาชอบมิลี่
หาพ่อมิลลี่ใช่ครับแต่ว่าวิลลี่ตอนเนี้ย
มิลลิเก่งมิลลิเก่งกว่ามากนะครับพลังของ
บิลลี่เนี่ยมีอยู่เยอะนะครับมีเลขก็เลย
บอกว่ามิลี่บอกฟรีกายบอกว่าถ้าอยากจะมาทำ
งานกับเขาอ่ะถ้าท้องเขาเนี่ยต้องไปเพิ่ม
พลังมาก่อนนี่ครับมิลลี่มิลี่ก็กดพลังของ
ตัวเองให้ให้ดูว่า Million มีพลังอยู่ 195
195 นะครับส่วนของของฟรีกายก็มีกายไม่
ใช่คนยังไม่เคยทำภารกิจอะไรเลยมีกายก็มี
คะแนนอยู่นิดเดียวของฟรีกายมีคะแนนอยู่ 1
คะแนน
มีพลัง
111 คะแนนมิลี่ก็บอกว่าฟรีกายไปเก็บ
คะแนนมาเยอะๆก่อนอ่ะเก็บคะแนนมาเยอะๆแล้ว
อ่าวิลลี่ก็จะให้มาทำงานด้วยกัน
มาเครียดที่ค่ะแล้วในเกมนี้เราจะเก็บ
คะแนนเก็บคะแนนให้เพิ่มขึ้นได้ยังไงคะใช่
หลายๆเจอก็ต้องยิงไปฆ่าคนๆครับในเกมนี้
เกมนี้ทุกคนเวลาที่จะเก็บคะแนนก็ต้องไปทำ
ภารกิจบางคนเข้าไปล่อนธนาคารปล้นธนาคาร
แบบที่ของฟรีกายอยู่ที่ธนาคารและมีคนมา
พ่นนั้นมือถือหรือไปฆ่าคนด้วยเหมือนกันนะ
ครับหน้าแป้งฟรีกายฟรีใดไม่ดีใจไม่อยาก
ฆ่าคนไม่อยากพ่นธนาคาร
หน้าฟรีไก่ก็เลยกลายจะเก็บคะแนนได้ยังไง
ได้พี่กายก็เลยเก็บคะแนนด้วยกันทำความดี
หน้าทำความดีเวลามีคนที่ถูกร่นถูกทำร้าย
ฟรีจ่ายก็เข้าไปช่วยเข้าไปช่วยคนต่างๆนะ
ครับก็ทำให้ฟรีกายเริ่มได้คะแนนได้คะแนน
มาเยอะนะครับหน้าเวลาที่ไปช่วยเหลือคนนะ
ครับนะพี่ใจก็เริ่มได้คะแนนมาเยอะนะครับ
แล้วก็ R หลังจากนั้นพี่ไก่ครับฟรีกายได้
ไปทำงานให้มีนี่ไหมคะได้ครับเพราะว่าวัน
นึงเวลาที่ฟรีกาย We  Are  kept คะแนน
เก็บคะแนนมาได้เยอะได้เยอะแล้วเท่ากับ
วิลลี่แล้วเนี่ยดีกายก็ไปทำงานกับมิลี่ไป
ช่วยมิลี่ค้นหาค้นหาอ่านโค้ดเกมหน้าว่า
อยู่ที่ไหนๆๆครับ
แล้วพออ่าพอฟรีกายฟรีกายไปอ่าไม่ไปทำงาน
ที่ธนาคารเพราะตอนนี้ตีกายจะไปทำงานกับ
วิลลี่แล้วอ่ะอ่ะ
ตัวประกอบตัวประกอบที่อยู่ในเกมนะครับก็
เลยมีไม่ครบคนที่จะเข้าไปปล้นธนาคารก้น
ไม่ได้เพราะว่าฟรีกายไม่อยู่ไม่อยู่ที่
ธนาคาร
น้าแล้วนอกฉาบฟรีกายไม่ไปทำงานแล้ว seikai
ยังไปบอกบอกกับเพื่อนๆคนอื่นอย่าบอกกับ
ตัวประกอบคนอื่นในเกมบอกว่าพวกเราไม่ต้อง
ไปทำงานก็ได้ 5 เราอยากไปที่ไหนก็ได้เรา
คิดเองคิดเองได้ไม่ต้องไปทำงาน
แล้วเพื่อนๆที่เป็นตัวประกอบในเกมเขา
เชื่อฟรีกายหรอคะเพื่อนๆก็เชื่อเพราะว่า
เพื่อนๆก็ไม่อยากไปทำงานเหมือนกัน 5 อยาก
จะไปเที่ยวอยากจะไปกินอาหารที่อื่นไม่
อยากไปทำงานอ่ะพอทุกคนความตัวประกอบในเกม
ไม่ไปทำงานคนที่เข้ามาเล่นเกมก็เล่นไม่
ได้
ใช่ครับเพราะว่าในเกมไม่มีคนไม่มีเจ้า
หน้าที่ไม่มีตำรวจไม่มีพนักงานธนาคารให้
เข้ามาปฏิบัติภารกิจ
ในเกมก็เลยเล่นไม่ได้
ก็ได้ครับ
เพราะเกมไม่ได้ลบเกิดอะไรขึ้นค่ะอ่ะพอเกม
เล่นไม่ได้แล้วของตัวนะครับคนที่เป็นเจ้า
ของเกมเวลาที่คนเล่นเกมไม่ได้อ่อมตัวนก็
จะไม่ได้เงินก็จะไม่ได้เงินก็เลยเห็นดู
ของตัวนี้ก็เลยมาดูว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นในเกม
ทำไมเกมเล่นไม่ได้หาของตัวนี้ก็เลยเห็น
เห็นว่าอามินลี่กับฟรีกายเนี่ยเข้าไปทำ
ให้คนในเกมไม่ยอมทำงาน
หน้า
ครับของชวนก็เลยต้องการที่จะหยุดฟรีกาย
แล้วก็หยุดมิลลี่ไม่ให้ไม่ให้ออกมาจากเกม
นะครับอ่าเพื่อให้ทุกคนกลับไปทำงานเหมือน
เดิม
นะครับ
ถ้ามีอะไรสุดยอดที่พบทุบคอมพิวเตอร์เหรอ
ใช่ครับของตัวนี้ก็เลยพร้อมชวนก็เลยโทรหา
เลยว่างเหรอคอมพิวเตอร์ทางเอ่อต้องเรียก
ว่าเป็นเซิร์ฟเวอร์ของเกมมีครับเขาถือ
ควายเข้ามาแล้วก็ค้าง Surf  Game เพื่อ
ให้เกมทางเพื่อให้ฟรีกายหยุดไหมครับน้า
ใช่ครับหนู
แต่ว่าถ้าคิดจินตนาการดูเฉยๆนะไม่คิดว่า
ออกตัวจะเอาทุบเพิ่มถ้วนเลยอองตวนไม่
สามารถหยุดฟรีกายได้ก็เลยคิดว่าอ้ามีวิธี
ถ้าอย่างนั้นก็พักคอมพิวเตอร์เลยให้ฟรี
กายหายไปนะครับ
แต่แต่ว่าออกตวนทำไม่สำเร็จเพราะว่าอะไร
หรือไม่ครับเพราะว่าฟรีกายว่าอะไรเพราะ
ว่าฟรีกรายกับเอมิลี่เนี่ยเข้าไปหาโค้ช
เจอโค้ชขอมิลี่ที่อยู่ในเกมอ่ะ
โค้ชของมีก็คือเป็นโค้ชที่เป็นเมืองใหม่
เมืองใหม่ที่ไม่เกี่ยวกับเกมส์ของที่นี่
ออกตวนเอาขวานไปฟันนะครับน่าจะเสร็จแล้ว
ฟรีกายก็มีแล้วมิลลี่กับฟรีไก่ก็เอา Code
อันนี้ออกมาแล้วก็สร้างเกมใหม่สร้างเกม
ใหม่ไม่เกี่ยวกับเกมเดิม
น้า
ใช่ครับแล้วก็สร้างเกมใหม่ชื่อเกม Free
Life
ครับหน้า
แล้วในเกมนี้ get  Free  Like ครับ
ที่ให้คนเข้าไปเล่นหรอคะอ่าให้คนเข้าไป
เข้าไปไม่ต้องปฏิบัติภารกิจเข้าไปดูเข้า
ไปดูอย่างเดียวไม่ต้องยิงก็ต้องเก็บคะแนน
เข้าไปดูว่าคนในเกมคนที่อยู่ในเกมจะทำ
อะไรกัน
หน้าทำอะไรก็ได้
โง่ใช่ครับก็คือเรื่องคิดว่ามันไม่เหมือน
เกมนะถ้าเกิดเกมเราก็ต้องเข้าไปเล่นอ่ะคะ
อันนี้เหมือนเข้าไปดูทีวีนะอ้าใช่ครับ
เข้าไปดูชีวิตของคนที่อยู่ในเกมว่าเขาทำ
อะไรเขามีอะไรเขาพัฒนาอะไรกันบ้างในเกม
นั้นอ่ะ
เขาน่ะแล้วในเรื่องนี้จะจบอ่าฟรีกายก็ได้
ไปอยู่ที่เมืองใหม่ไม่ต้องไปทำงานทุกวัน
ไม่ต้องไปเก็บคะแนนชาย
อ๋อแล้ว 4 กายก็ยังรักมีอีกไหมคะยังชอบปี
กายก็คอบชอบวิลลี่แต่ปีกลายรู้แล้วว่าอ่า
วิลลี่เนี่ยเป็นคนก็จะตีกายไม่ใช่คน
ชายที่จ่ายก็เลยอยู่อยู่อยู่ในเกม Free
Life แต่ครับ
อาหารหอมโอเคก็จบจอลงนะครับโอเค
ว้าวหนา
เป็นไงบ้างครับเรื่องนี้สนุกไหมครับ
รู้สึกว่า
รูปรู้สึกสนุกตรงที่หยุดเหมือนแบบชีวิต
เราชีวิตเรียงชีวิต Arty เทียบที่ 5 แล้ว
ก็เหมือนเราใช้ชีวิตไปนานๆแล้วเราไม่ได้
รู้ว่าเราคิดคิดที่จะเลือกสิ่งที่เราชอบ
ได้จริงๆๆ
ใช่ครับอ่ายังอันนี้ก็ฟรีกายเขาก็เริ่ม
คิดได้ว่าเขาอยากทำอะไรเขาก็ได้ไปทำนะ
ครับนะเพราะเขาเริ่มคิดว่า
มีชีวิตของเขาต้องต้องทำอะไรที่ไม่เหมือน
เดิมได้ด้วยตัวของเขาเองทำ
ใช่โอเคนะครับ 5 วันนี้ก็หมดเวลาแล้วนะ
ครับเดี๋ยวเรากลับมาเจอกันใหม่คราวหน้านะ
ครับว่าเฮียตี๋แล้วก็นักเรียนจากมันเล่า
นั้นเรื่องอะไรให้ฟังนะคอยติดตามกันนะ
ครับโอเคก็วันนี้ก็ได้แล้วค่ะวันนี้ลาสอง
คนต้องลาไปก่อนนะคะสวัสดี
ค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้นักเรียนใส่ครับนักเรียน
บ๊ายบาย
[เพลง]